hey Vsauce Michael here and I am in
Regent's Park in London
joined by Tom from slash Tom awesome
check it out
this camera belongs to Tom and Hazel is
operating it right now yeah
that's right give you a thumbs up which
I'm sure just look like the floor but
the point is I'm going to give
information today right now Tom I am in
London England and it's also the United
Kingdom is in Europe okay and we've also
got another term Great Britain let's
unpack all these terms and today learn
about geography
can I find someone else now if we're
gonna talk about geography I think we
should go all the way back to a time
when there was no geography that's right
way before YouTube existed our solar
system was nothing but a mist of dust
and gases what is known as a solar
nebula but then about 4.6 billion years
ago something majestic happened we don't
know exactly what caused it but some
scientists believe that the shockwave of
a nearby supernova hit our nebula
causing it to start spinning and
contracting now as things collected
together their overall gravity got
stronger and they pulled more stuff in
and in boom we've got a Sun a half
billion years later and the disk of junk
circling around the Sun starts coming
together in its own way into what we now
call the planets one of these planets
I've actually visited and it's called
Earth but before we get ahead of
ourselves what the heck is the moon
doing there I mean here's the problem
when you look at all the terrestrial
planets all the planets near us near the
Sun they all have very similar structure
and they all have the same big metal
core and they all have very similar
densities but the moon is very not dense
and it doesn't have a similar structure
doesn't have a huge dense metal core in
fact when we visited the moon and
brought back dust and rocks to analyze
what the moon was made out of we found
that the moon was made out of the same
stuff that you find in Earth's crust and
mantle but not Earth's core
this discovery gave rise to a pretty
awesome idea that the moon is actually
made out of what used to be on earth
about 4.5 2 billion years ago there used
to be another planet called fea it was a
little bit smaller than Mars but it had
an unfortunate orbit it was fine for
millions of years but eventually and
what did happen to it was that it
collided with earth
now it's believed that the collision
happened quite slowly and the center's
the cores of both fááááá and earth fused
into one and material from the mantle
and crust of Earth wasn't just scattered
but it was forcefully ejected literally
launched into outer space it circled
around Earth and scientists believe that
it took only about a week for all that
earth material out in space to coalesce
into what we now call the moon oh and by
the way if that's how the moon formed it
was such a strong collision the actual
axis that the earth spun on was tilted
23.5 degrees which to this day is why we
have seasons Wow
all right so four billion years ago the
continents as we know them began to
emerge
you know these pieces of the Earth's
crust that have cooled down and are
floating around on Earth's molten liquid
insides now they move and they've been
in constant motion since they began but
they move very very slowly every 300 to
500 million years the continents all
converge into what's called one big
supercontinent all the land in the
entire earth altogether and the rest of
it covered an ocean
the most recent supercontinent is kind
of famous it's called Pangaea but
scientists believe that there may have
been four five six or even more super
continents that existed before Pangaea
what's really mind-blowing is the fact
that eventually there's going to be
another Pangaea another supercontinent
and based on calculations the earth at
that time will look like
but like I said these land masses are
moving very very slowly and so for that
reason it is worth learning their names
as they are now which brings us back to
the question of England United Kingdom
Great Britain British Isles and what all
these terms mean let's begin
zoomed out the British Isles in Ireland
are a collection of six thousand islands
off the coast of Europe the term Great
Britain refers to the largest of these
islands now Great Britain contains three
separate countries England Wales and
Scotland if we add more than Ireland
into the mix we're now looking at what
is known as the United Kingdom or the UK
the Republic of Ireland is a separate
country that is not part of the United
Kingdom and by the way England is where
London is which is where summer in the
city was which brings us back to Regents
Park and as always thanks for
[Applause]
could you guys stand still for a second
hey Larry to learn more about Great
Britain Ireland overseas territories and
even Canada you really must check out
CGP grey explanation video if you
haven't seen it already this guy is
incredible you can also check out the
channels belonging the people who helped
me with the intro and outro for this
video we've got Tom and dude where's my
challenge
[Music]